hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome to another installment of what
you never knew this is where we take a
look at all the little touches not
behind the scenes of a movie but right
in front of us and today we're gonna
take a gander at Who Framed Roger Rabbit
sure it's an awesome movie it has some
of history's most famous cartoon
characters but have you ever noticed all
the tiny things in the background the
subtle touches the graceful nod the itty
bittys you never noticed unless you
watch the movie a million times like I
have and well those hours of watching
have added up to this video pointing out
the many easter eggs this movie has
hidden right in front of us there's a
great ton of them and there's no time to
lose let's take a look at Roger Rabbit
we all know Bob Hoskins and Christopher
Lloyd but there's a few other people you
may recognize that act in this film for
example the dip shoe was voiced by Bart
Simpson star Nancy Cartwright the voice
of droopy on the elevator is done by the
film's animation director Richard
Williams I'll take the game and how
about lieutenant Santino does his
condescending attitude ring any bells to
you gee whiz and if you needed money so
bad why didn't you come to me don't try
to frighten us with your sorcerers ways
lord Vader that's right he was the guy
who got choked into being Vader's bitch
in Star Wars don't feel too bad
I knew another lieutenant who didn't
turn out so great in Star Wars either
while most of us know an uncredited
Kathleen Turner voice Jessica Rabbit the
singing voice was done by producer
Steven Spielberg's then wife Amy Irving
on top of that you'll notice that half
the dialogue that Donald speaks is taken
from the original cartoons where he was
voiced by Clarence Charles Wong's
and the other audio being the new
dialogue was voiced by his replacement
Tony as Elmo
anybody understand what this duck is
saying the oven in the intro may look
like a foreign company but you ever try
reading it out loud if you do it would
sound like hotter in hell yeah I know
but let's face it they've had worse than
you uncle's in this movie nice blue eat
rip the book the film was based on who's
censored Roger Rabbit was actually an
allegory to racism against African
Americans in the 40s now while Lovitz
played down in the film the hints and
clues are still there being campaign
club for example where tooms go to
perform and serve yet aren't allowed to
watch it's a satire of a similar
establishment called the Cotton Club the
red car being bought out to make a
freeway was based on a real plan to tear
down poor neighborhoods to sell more
automobiles you see how important the
red car is in this time period by the
map is in the bar and you see the plan
being put into place with an ad right
next to toontown advertising cloverleaf
homes Eddie is also overcoming a
prejudice that Rogers dialog suggests
it's becoming more and more common you
know there's no justice for too many
more that can be a very powerful thing
why sometimes in life it's the only
weapon we have Roger even subtly stands
on a soapbox when making a speech about
surviving injustice clever this is one
of the few times in history you've seen
Mickey Mouse with Bugs Bunny and Donald
Duck with Daffy Duck but have you ever
noticed they're never on screen alone
they're always side by side that's
because Warner Brothers made an
arrangement that they're top stars bugs
and Daffy get just as much screen time
as Disney's top stars Mickey and Donald
in fact only 10 characters in the entire
film are not copyrighted by Disney
that's one of the reasons toontown is
primarily filled with Disney characters
no wonder they were constantly fighting
all the time
a lot of us pickup judge dooms rubbery
phase teeth and exaggerate still two
movements indicating that he's an evil
toon in disguise but have you ever
noticed another clue most evil cartoon
characters had back then that he
constantly has there's almost always a
gust of wind blowing his cape back yep
even indoors somehow that little cave
always keeps blowing sinisterly
backwards subtle don't you appreciate
the magnitude of that there's a few
references younger audiences might not
get but are definitely products of the
time when Roger cuts Eddy he's doing an
impression of popular comic strip Dick
Tracy
Eddy value and remember Angelo's
imaginary friend when doom is looking
for Roger say hello oh that's a
reference to a popular Jimmy Stewart
movie about a man who sees an imaginary
rabbit the owner of maroon cartoons is
also a satire of an insult that was
thrown around quite a bit back back wet
in my room I remember this line
Brooklyn Dodgers I gave vibes on why
that's foreshadowing that the Brooklyn
Dodgers would eventually move to
California and become the LA Dodgers
meaning those bums he was complaining
about he'd soon be rooting for in the
future there's no way to make a legend
does Roger hatha force because he lifted
that code up before even touching it if
you ever wonder why Eddy is taking a
shower in the middle of the day it's to
wipe away a torture device that judge
doom put that Eddy in a deleted scene
well not torture but more humiliation
you can see more of that scene in the
special edition DVD what you can't see
in the special edition DVD is a
controversial couple of frames where
Jessica is thrown out of the car it
reveals that she went commando under
that dress that's right it's not even a
second long but she flashes the camera
out and open this was caught on VHS and
removed when the DVD was released fair
enough but how come that wind and Lion
King still says sex mat sure it is that
wonderful shot of Eddie's des presents a
history of him and his brother being
jokesters showing that a lot of the
background pictures in this film show a
much more completed story for example
Eddie's backflips and juggling are
suggested by his father and his brother
being in the circus we also see Betty
Boop is the only toon he seems to have a
nostalgic respect for and thus it's the
only piece of two merchandise he keeps
in his office yeah you still got it well
all the cartoons were of course animated
there were one or two shots that were
too quick or too dangerous to perform
with human actors this meant that
Hoskins himself had to be animated for a
couple of shots weird Tony when do looks
at the merry-go-round broke down a
record that Roger was playing earlier he
deems it like a loony selection for a
group of drunken reprobates this is very
fitting seeing how the merry-go-round
broke down is the main theme for the
Looney tune shorts
my buddy very be a sourpuss
now how he could tell he was there by
smelling it
that's just odd good boss not good luck
vision you need a permit for escape
proof tune rope use that escape rope to
rope I mean don't get me wrong I know
why they use it as we clearly see Roger
can slip out of any bindings but the
term escape proof tune rope would
indicate it would only be needed to
restrain or hang someone in fact jessica
has a few strands around her neck and
somehow miraculously doesn't seem to
choke this is a pretty fucked up product
the more I think about it that's what I
call one seriously disturbed - and the
number one thing you never knew about
Roger Rabbit is pretty much everything
in the background of toontown
okay so there's way too many signs and
little touches all throughout this scene
and I doubt I can name all them in such
a short video so here's just a quick sum
up of the festival the movie theater
indicates they change their shorts daily
the first popular cartoon series Felix
the Cat is on top of the toontown tunnel
proving that does in fact have a very
long history the shadows of both the
roadrunner and coyote are seen in the
elevator indicating they're searching
for one another throughout the building
the Jessica imposter has a shoe tree
outside her door I don't like what
that's indicating everything in toontown
has a happy face even the clouds creepy
Eddie's Tim Gunn was given to him by
Yosemite Sam who apparently did time I
can't imagine for what and my absolute
favorite out all of them oh hell just
read it that is fucking hilarious and
one of the many little touches that
makes Roger Rabbit an absolutely awesome
movie
are there any more that you noticed are
there any other little touches we're
talking about well leave them in the
comments below and keep talking about a
movie that's definitely we're talking
about I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember so you don't have to